-Our first guest tonight
is a talented actor
you know from the hit show
"Brooklyn Nine Nine."
He's also the host
of "America's Got Talent,"
which airs Tuesday nights
here on NBC.
Please welcome
back to the show,
our friend Terry Crews.
How are you, Terry?
-Hey, what's up, Seth?
How you doing, man?
I'm good!
-I'm glad to hear it.
We're very excited for
the eighth and final seaso
of "Brooklyn Nine Nine"
to start airing.
I know that you guys wrapped
I talked to Andy,
who said it was emotional.
You guys were saying goodbye
I know you've
said goodbye before,
and then the show went
from Fox to NBC,
but how was this time,
knowing it was final?
-Oh, my God.
First of all,
there were so many tears.
So many hugs.
It was incredible.
I mean, you have to understand
you know,
you spend more time
with these castmates
than you do your own family.
You know?
-Yeah.
-It's true.
And you go, "Oh, my God, like,
this is the connection we had.
And what was so beautiful --
I've been in places where
things tended to fall apart.
Like, you're there with people
and all of a sudden you're like,
"I don't like them anymore,"
you know?
But it did not happen
on this show.
We actually got
closer and closer
and better and better,
and what can I say, man?
I feel like when
I move across the country,
I know I'm moving away
and everything's different now
I'm kind of going through
a little bit of depression
a little mourning.
'Cause you have to
acknowledge it,
because it's changed.
Everything's gone.
You may not work with
these people again,
and that's a reality,
and it's really,
really deep, man.
-Well, I think it'll be
also very emotional
for the rest of us
when we see the finally episode.
So you're a little bit
in our future
of having already
dealt with the goodbye.
You know, you mentioned
spending more time with cast
than you do your family,
but you have done
a very smart thing which is,
you and your wife
wrote a book together,
so you have both
a relationship outside of work
and then you guys found a wa
to do something together.
How was it collaborating?
-First of all,
the reason we made this book
and Audible gave us a shot
at doing this,
it's because we've
been married 32 years
and we didn't know
what we were doing.
You know?
And all I wanted --
I was just like,
"Man, if someone had
told me this, my God."
And you know what,
we decided to be that couple
for other people.
It was like,
if you were interested,
if you really want to know
what it's like.
Because this is the thing --
being married,
it's always this fantasy is,
everything's got to be great
and the fantasy is,
everything's gonna be wonderfu
or it's all over.
And our message is that
it's going to be tough.
It's going to be
unbelievably tough,
but it's worth it.
It's worth it.
When you get through
those tough times,
you are stronger together.
It's a little bit like
what we've been through
in this pandemic.
It's kind of like, you hol
the people who are dear to you
much, much closer because yo
don't take things for granted.
This is the advice we
really wanted to give
to young couples out there
because these times are coming
It's like,
it's totally inevitable.
You're not strange. You're not
alone, and you're not weird.
It's just real.
-Now, one of the things
I think that married couples
a lot of them, at least,
can be proudest of
are their children.
And this is really cool --
your son Isaiah
has gone into acting.
He has a role in the show
"Side Hustle,"
and here you guys are
hanging out together.
Now, is this something
you always knew was gonna
happen with Isaiah?
That he was gonna follow
his dad's footsteps?
-No. You know, first of all,
I never wanted to be that gu
who put things on my kids,
'cause my dad always wanted me
to go to Army,
and I didn't want to go
to the Army.
And all he talked about
was how much he wanted me
to go into Army.
You feel like you disappointed
him, and the whole thing.
I would never put
that pressure on my kids.
But he really took to it.
I mean, he started auditioning
and what was the hardest part,
like, for four or five years
he was getting rejected.
That's part of being an actor.
It was hard to watch.
It was hard to
go through with him
but it was like,
as long as you want to
keep doing this,
this is the reality,
and he kept going.
People think, "Oh, my God,
it's nepotism.
Of course, Terry Crews' son.
He was getting totally rejecte
all the time,
and finally it broke through
-Well, that's really great
And I'll tell you this --
I'm glad he went into acting
'cause this haircut
would not fly in the Army.
Would not, not for one day
-I used to have
that same haircut.
It's all gone now.
-Hey, so, "America's Got Talent"
is back.
This is your
third season hosting.
You have an in-studio audience
back again.
For a show like that,
I can imagine it just
makes a massive difference
-Oh yeah.
First of all,
I get jealous of people
who are, like, comedians,
because they get to do
live shows all the time,
so I decided to
get my own live show.
I said, "I'm gonna host 'ATG,'
so I can get this live love.
And you know, we did
last season in a pandemic,
so what was crazy is that
we didn't have a crowd,
but now we had
a limited audience,
and then once
the Dolby live shows come back
we're going to be full force
everything back 100%.
It's the best thing ever, dude
I am a 100% honey baked ham.
I need that people.
I need that energy.
That's why I pop my pecs.
That's why I do what I do.
I need it,
and I can't wait to have it.
-I think there are a lot o
reasons you pop your pecs,
let's be honest.
Now, you got to use
the Golden Buzzer.
For those who don't know,
that makes an act automaticall
advance to the next round.
Tell us, was it
World Taekwondo?
-Yes, the World Taekwondo
demonstration team.
These guys were
absolutely insane.
Men, women,
there were Americans.
There were South Koreans.
There were people
from all over the world,
and they put on
a demonstration.
Human beings actually
flew across the stage.
There was shrapnel
flying everywhere.
I was ducking and dodging
the whole time,
and I was thrilled.
It was absolutely incredible
These guys weren't able
to go to the Olympics
because of COVID.
But they will be at
our live shows,
because I had to give them
the Golden Buzzer,
which was just as good
as a gold medal.
I like to say that.
-Now, I do want to show
a clip about it.
You tend to be a fairly
enthusiastic person,
but I felt like you kept
your emotions really muted
and in check here.
Let's take a look.
-Okay.
-[ Group chanting ]
Yes! Yes! Yes! Yes!
Yes! Yes! Yes! Yes! Yes!
Yes! Yes! Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I will say, that does loo
like an action movie
where they're about to
all attack you one by one.
-[ Laughing ] I know.
Well, actually, it was funny
That's just after
a couple espressos.
-That's just normal.
-They hadn't even performed yet.
You should have seen me
after the whole thing.
It was incredible.
-Hey, this is very exciting.
You got a birthday coming up
end of July,
and you're also getting a star
on the Hollywood Walk of Fame.
Congratulations, Terry.
That's quite an honor.
-You know what, anybody wh
always wanted to stop on me,
you can do it.
This is an opportunity
for anyone.
-But you will find them
if they do.
-Yeah.
-You will track them down.
-I've got a little camera
set right there.
But listen, man, what an honor
What can I say, man?
I'm a little kid from
Flint, Michigan, bro,
and I'm like, to get this honor,
to be there
amongst all these greats,
dude, I'm in free play lan
every time,
and it never ceases to amaze me.
-Congratulations again.
Love to you and your family,
and we look forward to
seeing you soon.
-Thank you, Seth.
-"America's Got Talent" airs
Tuesday nights here on NBC